well well well look who's shopping on
the russian oil market
the u.s purchased record-breaking
volumes of russian crude in 2020
making moscow its third largest oil
supplier
even saudi arabia long-standing american
ally and one of the world's
largest oil exporters is left behind
while this can't be true you would say
the u.s
is increasingly buying a valuable
commodity filling the coffers of a
country
it deems to be one of the most
formidable foes i mean
where is the logic maybe it's a mistake
you know
a one-time thing well not really
according to the u.s energy information
administration
america has been ramping up its oil
imports from russia
for the last five years until they
finally broke a decade old record
and that's despite all the hostility
tension harsh rhetoric
well you would say trade is above
politics but
wasn't the u.s the country that bashed
europeans for doing
the same thing wanting to buy say gas
from russia
remember what they said and are still
saying about nordstream 2.
the pipeline is a bad idea bad for
bad for europe bad for the united states
ultimately
it's in contradiction to the eu's own
energy security goals so let me get this
straight it's a bad idea when
europe buys russian energy but for the
u.s
it's fine washington is just trying to
be responsible and
protect its weak european allies from
russia's political leverage
and its malicious energy ambitions by
fearlessly grabbing it themselves and
it's not just
fossil fuel america still buys rocket
engines
and pays russia to send its astronauts
to the international space station
it also gets russian titanium for boeing
place there too
but jokes aside at the end of the day
oil is something that
millions rely on in their day-to-day
life electricity
transportation you name it and if the us
so
desperately needs extra fuel for its
people
and even ready to buy it from its
perceived enemy
there is probably a good reason for it
at least that's what i thought
but it appears that the u.s had to turn
to the russian energy market
largely because their own sanctions had
suffocated oil production
in venezuela its historic trading
partner
u.s refineries in the gulf of mexico are
some of the most
sophisticated plants in the world having
lost
venezuelan crude and facing less and
more
expensive feedstock from the traditional
opec
suppliers they have become a major
customer for russian fuel oil as a
substitute
so to recap the u.s shuts down one
oil producer says he was a bad guy
realizes it now
doesn't have enough oil turns to another
producer says well
you're a bad guy too but i'm gonna buy
stuff from you anyway
at the same time it tries to intimidate
all
other customers for doing exactly what
they are doing
so much for trademark american diplomacy
that as joe biden says is now back